like I've always telling you Ronald
people and all country moon genuine they
treat each other with respect if a man
has something to say he says it to your
face well widely bet is what what go
away Clegg we're closed
oh he is not here to gamble van are you
your o-tar I am mr. but covelli yes who
are you I'm here on behalf of a
concerned third party here that no no
our guest is a very private person I
found it pays to be cautious when you
don't know exactly who you're dealing
with that is true but sometimes it could
create the problems which could have
been avoided that they've been more
forthcoming if neither man is willing to
compromise the chemical reach a
satisfactory understanding i would like
to avoid any misunderstandings good so
in this case in jordan know my name no
doubt other things about me I think you
owe me the same courtesy
I know this you're clearly an
intelligent man i doubt if there's
anything about me you haven't already
figured out obviously I'm here on behalf
of Vaclav Kohler he's waiting for a
shipment from you I'm sure this is all
just a simple misunderstanding the only
thing I've learned about you so far is
that you don't understand the first rule
of good relations they begin with mutual
respect as for caller there was no
misunderstanding he wanted the
calibrator and I refused the same as i
am doing to you this is why i do not
like dealing with Boggs follow my
business caller must be desperate to
send someone like him a second ago you
were talking about respect now you're
acting like I'm not even in the room I'm
here because color is the only man in
town who can do the repairs I need
that's the truth how about you show me
the same courtesy you see I know now he
is being honest too honest you talk
about respect and show none Bunnel
mr. Bhatt cofely would like you to leave
now
don't bother me
what were you thinking
stations continue
anomaly detected trace / access granted
in Russia acting all about drone attacks
damn
anomaly detected trace program initiated
access granted all right come on I've
got your neuro plasticity calibrator
that's great